[Music]
on this Saturday night a grim milestone
500 Days of fighting and sacrifice for
Ukraine since the Russian invasion we
look at Ukraine's next moves to regain
territory they need a boost and this can
provide that boost as Western Nations
prepare to discuss its request to join
NATO
hate on the rise of what's fueling this
wave of attacks and why it's more
important than ever to report and track
them
saddling up in the switch from surviving
to thriving and I think there's a little
pent-up demand from our American friends
and why challenges remain for Canada's
tourism industry
pulling on threads what a lawsuit
against meta's so-called Twitter killer
app signals
global national with Farah Nasser
reporting tonight
and gabiola
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a war in Ukraine which has
reached another somber Milestone it's
now been 500 Days since Russia invaded
the country
since February 24th of last year there
have been 25
170 civilian casualties that includes
more than nine thousand kills and more
than fifteen thousand injured military
casualties on both sides are difficult
to establish and verify more than 6
million ukrainians have become refugees
since the start of the war
and there is no end in sight to the
fighting which has left some families
forced to say goodbye to their loved
ones and others picking up the pieces of
a life Shattered by conflict Mackenzie
gray reports
it's an all too common scene after 500
Days of War at least 10 dead in Western
Ukraine after a Russian missile landed
in a residential area of levit
for those who survive there's often
nothing left to come home to
that's exactly what happened to the
zirtusky family who fled Kiev after
their house burned down now calling the
Ukrainian Countryside home
Olga forced to cook Outdoors for her
family of five while her husband Igor
watches their children in a tiny wooden
home President Vladimir zelinski paying
tribute to millions of ukrainians who've
sacrificed during the war on a visit to
snake island with a tiny village in the
Black Sea the ukrainians were able to
retake from the Russians
the potential to regain more territory
got a boost with Joe Biden announcing
the U.S would deliver cluster bombs to
Kiev they're a controversial weapon that
releases a large number of smaller
bomblets that can kill indiscriminately
over a wide area but those that don't
explode pose a long-term threat
depending on how they land some of them
don't go off and will hang around in
that number is anywhere from two percent
on up depending on uh the terrain and
civilians can happen upon these their
weapon Canada and many other Western
allies have banned the UK is signatory
to a convention which prohibits the
production or use of cluster Munitions
and discourages their use Western
countries are also split on Ukraine's
request to join NATO but on Friday
zelinski was able to get an unexpected
endorsement when Turkish president Tai
berdawan said Ukraine undoubtedly
deserves to be a member of the alliance
A Step the White House is uneasy of the
United States our NATO allies in Ukraine
will have the opportunity to discuss the
reforms that are still necessary for
NATO for Ukraine to come up to Nato
standards that conversation will likely
intensify next week when leaders from
all 31 NATO countries will meet in
Lithuania but as it stands now Anne
zilinsi is not expected to attend that
conference
that is Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you
[Music]
and on this 500th day of War a
homecoming for Heroes Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski greeting
five commanders in Istanbul they were
forced to live in Turkey under the terms
of a prisoner exchange the commanders
LED last year's defense of the port in
maripole zielinski gave no explanation
for why the commanders were being
allowed to return home now
and there is movement on the push for a
public inquiry into foreign interference
in Canada
the conservatives say an agreement has
been reached on terms for the probe
stating all parties have shared their
suggested names for a potential
commissioner the deal has yet to be
confirmed by the Trudeau government it
appears to break the impasse between the
Liberals and conservatives about how to
establish an inquiry into foreign
interference in Canada's Federal
elections
and police in Ottawa are sounding the
alarm over a significant rise in hate
crimes in that City since January there
have been more than 200 hate motivated
incidents as Easton ham reports it's an
alarming Trend being seen right across
the country
volunteers of different face and
backgrounds came together in Vancouver
today to restore seven Pride doors that
had been vandalized at a church on the
city's West Side the message of today is
determination against hate in the world
and where so we repaint repaint and
repaint it's a show of unity after
repeated hate crimes police saying this
was the third time in as many years the
church was targeted it's annoying worse
than that it is a horrific message to
the 2s lgbtqa Community unfortunately
they're not alone just this week a man
in Kelowna was caught jumping to rip a
pride flag hanging from an art gallery
anti-semitic pamphlets were distributed
in the city of Peterborough and in
Ottawa 221 hate motivated incidents were
reported in the first half of 2023
Diamond was six months in so you can
it's it's around 30 35 files a month
that are coming into our office that's
nearly a 24 jump from the same time last
year the diverse communities and the 2s
LGBT qqia plus community that is is
being affected by this uh it's
concerning to them the executive
director Ride Toronto telling Global
News it's time for leaders to act we
call on all three levels of government
to hold folks accountable there is no
room we can no longer sit by and just
allow that level of hate to the 2s lgbtq
Community continue experts say motivated
incidents are on the rise right across
the country what we're seeing is that
over the last 10 years
it's hate crime in Canada reported hate
crime has uh doubled Doug King says
misinformation during the pandemic could
be partly to blame but adds there's
still a large amount of hate crimes that
go unreported so what was kind of
fueling that was largely the conspiracy
theories that were being floated around
in on social networks as numbers grow
the message from those cleaning up these
instances of hate remain the same this
community will not quit well it's just
the the constant proof that love wins
and that the darkness will not overcome
Eastern ham Global News
and it is the first weekend of the
Calgary Stampede and for the first time
since the pandemic International
visitors seem eager to come back to the
10-day event early ticket sales have
surpassed 2019 levels with American and
European tourists helping to drive
numbers up with International borders
free of pandemic restrictions this
summer There's Hope the tourism sector
is finally on the rebound Heather your
ex West reports
in Alberta summary doesn't truly start
until there's a parade
in a normal year the Calgary Stampede
draws about a million visitors to the
city and with them a whole lot of
spending let's look at it by the Numbers
eight billion dollars that comes to
Alberta every year about for tourism the
Stampede alone is half a billion there
we go of course things haven't been
normal for the tourism sector since 2019
while last summer saw Signature Events
stage comebacks many International
visitors stayed away last year of course
we still had restrictions at the border
with regard to vaccination requirements
this year there are no such restrictions
and I think there's a little pent-up
demand from our American friends because
they're coming back zaped isn't
expecting to break attendance records
this year but it is hoping to see the
kind of numbers it saw pre-pandemic a
path Canada's tourism industry as a
whole is tracking towards as well we're
a year earlier than we thought we would
be in the recovery we're at 93 percent
of 2019 levels and we fully expect to be
at 2019 levels that was our best tourism
year on record by the end of 23 finding
workers to support all these Good Times
continues to be a challenge according to
the tourism industry Association of
Canada heading into the summer the
national tourism Workforce was short
nearly 100
000 people it's great to see this
stampede uh all the tents were able to
fill up you know all their positions but
labor in the province has been tough
Beau Valley area especially in the
Mountain Resort communities west of
Calgary zero percent housing vacancy has
made hiring especially hard the problem
compounded over the Canada Day long
weekend when a Lake Louise staff
residents housing hundreds of workers
went up in Flames the federal tourism
Minister says building affordable
housing in these communities is priority
one so it means working with the
municipalities to figure out how we can
open up the land with the municipalities
to build more housing full stop it needs
to be social housing affordable housing
and attainable housing and that's what
the National Housing strategy is for
rival and recovery mode Heather York's
West Global News Calgary
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's a political flip of sorts on
day two of the Stampede prime minister
Justin Trudeau showed off some skill on
the grill flipping Flapjacks this
morning at the ismaili pancake breakfast
not to be outdone by opposition leader
Pierre pualev the born and raised
calgarian also made an appearance at one
of the many Stampede breakfasts around
town alongside Alberta Premier Danielle
Smith
and the cost of borrowing is set to
become even more expensive
coming up a growing chorus of economists
warn household budgets should brace for
another interest rate hike
Canada's labor market continues to churn
out jobs providing momentum for a
growing consensus among economists who
expect a small rate hike on Wednesday
now all six of Canada's biggest
commercial Banks expect a quarter of a
percentage Point increase to the bank of
Canada's key interest rate the latest
snapshot of the expanding job market
shows the creation of sixty thousand
positions in June even as the jobless
rate ticked higher that's because
immigration increased the size of the
job market and also pushed up the number
of people looking for a job joining me
to discuss is Nate thuft with Manulife
Investment Management welcome
great to have Peter thank you Nate we
are finally seeing signs that the
Canadian economy is slowing you know
inflation has ease the job Market's
still strong but wage growth has slowed
could we achieve that elusive soft
landing and Dodge a recession
I mean there's a there's a theoretical
reason that you could but I think the
risk is still pretty high that we do see
a period of outright recession or simply
slow growth and the reality is there
isn't much difference between that
there's still going to be a level of
pain felt by a lot of consumers and a
lot of the general public based on the
higher rates that we've seen the the
Central Bank raise over the last year or
so and the simple reality is a lot of
that pain is probably still yet to come
in the markets okay so not the greatest
news there the bank of Canada's next
interest rate announcement is Wednesday
money markets are betting on a 25 basis
point increase of all the economists
I've interviewed this week only one
expects our Central Bank to pause what
do you see in your crystal ball
unfortunately our base case is we too do
see a 25 basis point height now whether
it's the right thing to do or not is a
question because as I said earlier
there's a lot of the increase in rates
that have still yet to be felt by the
markets and the overall economy there's
a big wag and the quarter point probably
doesn't mean a lot in the grand scheme
of things because it's just another 25
basis points on the 400 to 500 they've
already raised but you know it is
something that they're sticking to the
theme that they must wash inflation and
their rhetoric has been very clear that
they're focused on that and therefore we
do expect another quarter point this
coming week
okay and the Bank of Canada we know it
started its aggressive great hiking
cycle last March historically it takes
about 18 months for increases to be
fully felt throughout the economy we are
seeing signs that they're working but in
many ways this is just the tip of the
iceberg I'm thinking of those mortgages
that will be up for renewal is there a
danger in keeping interest rates at the
highest levels we've seen in a
generation
there's absolute danger and I think
that's
that's relative to the impacts to the
economy we know there's a lot more to
come through from these rate hikes that
we haven't seen in everyday life and the
mortgage area is one in particular in
Canada that's quite unique relative to
other geographies around the globe and
and that pain is still to come in many
cases but at the same time they're
focused on the broader inflation story
and inflation is a complex topic there's
lots of areas inflation that are still
arguably running too strong Beyond just
the idea that your interest rate costs
and your mortgage costs are going up
they're looking at the whole picture of
inflation and there is more work to do
to get to the ballpark that they're
focused on
yeah not a ton of time left but I do
want to ask you so we know interest
rates are the tool that the Bank of
Canada has to tackle inflation but there
are other factors that could dampen
inflation and economic growth for
example a prolonged strike at BC ports
also immigration tends to have a
dampening effect on wages and inflation
how much of an impact do you think those
internal factors can have
well there's a lot of impasse inflation
is a very complex story because there
are a lot of drivers of inflation that
are still at play at the same time some
of those drivers are starting to see a
level of alleviation such as supply
chain issues but at the same time as you
noted there's a lot of external factors
that are still at play so what the
central bank is doing there's only one
component of the fight against inflation
and in many cases their fight against
inflation doesn't actually solve all the
inflation story and so there is a
multi-faceted approach here that has to
be taken to truly solve the challenge of
controlling inflation in the coming
years
we'll have to leave it there thank you
so much for your time and your Insight
that was Nate thuft of Manulife
Investment Management thanks so much for
joining us
thank you
[Music]
life imitates art ahead how a former spy
is using his experience to create
incredibly detailed prosthetics
when someone is visibly disfigured by a
traumatic accident or birth defect there
can be a constant barrage of awkward
stares and questions but for some that
all changed after meeting an expert in
the field of disguises in a story
originally featured on the new reality
Jackson prosco introduces us to a former
spy who's embarked on a new mission
these are the hands of an artist a man
whose work is so detailed and so precise
you'd think it's real and that's the
point because Robert Barons art imitates
life that looks like skin doesn't it I
mastered the technique making silicone
look like skin from his small lab near
Washington DC Robert Kraft's Prosthetics
that are so realistic injuries and
genetic deformities become invisible for
Robert's patience it's life-changing
[Applause]
[Music]
traveled here from West Virginia cancer
took his ear and much of the surrounding
tissue from his neck and face today he's
getting the first fitting of the complex
silicone prosthetic Robert has been
crafting let him feel it on there it's
like very light but this is just the
beginning Robert will now spend hours
doing what no one else can tinting the
ear and skin flap in meticulous detail
so that it perfectly Blends in with
Steve's skin tomorrow Steve will see and
wear his finished prosthetic for the
very first time
it's a great psychological benefit in
their mental physical and social
well-being when I get up in the morning
I know when I go to work I'm going to
make a difference in someone's life
some artists want fame but Robert is not
a typical Creator he built his
reputation in a place where success
means nobody recognizes your work that's
because he honed his skills as a
real-life Master of Disguise at the CIA
and eventually developed full face
silicone masks that were Flawless
Robert's work allowed American
operatives to completely change their
appearance even their ethnicity in an
instance
they could put it on in three seconds
three seconds and take it off in three
seconds a complete face yes absolutely
that sounds like something out of
Mission Impossible
how about Mission possible
later he studied under biomedical
sculptors who exposed him to the reality
of a hidden world a world of people who
were tragically disfigured just like the
spies these people wanted to move
through life without attracting
attention suddenly Robert had a plan for
life after the CIA and the light went on
and I said to myself if you can put
people in hiding
you can bring people out of hiding
and when Steve Butler returned for his
next appointment Robert made a few final
touches and then it was Steve's turn to
take a look in the mirror
that's incredible
unbelievable after a career devoted to
remarkable Artistry he knows someone's
life depends on his next invisible
masterpiece
Jackson prosco Global News
[Music]
Twitter versus
social media rivals
[Music]
since meta's threads launched Wednesday
it has become one of the most rapidly
downloaded apps now surpassing 80
million users it's targeting those
wanting alternatives to Twitter after
some unfavorable changes to the platform
now Twitter is threatening legal action
accusing its rival of being a copycat
Mike trolllay reports
watch any sidewalk for a few minutes and
without a doubt you'll come across a
social media zombie in other words the
prize eyeballs in a digital cage fight
between Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
and man it's getting good I don't know
if there's room for another media social
media right now but I think Twitter's
had its day Elon Musk is completely
ruined Twitter when it comes to social
media Twitter is still King with over
230 million users others have tried to
take market share but none of Mastodon
true social or blue sky have made much
of a dent even with musk's habit of
posting polarizing right-wing tweets
I'll say what I want to say and if if if
the consequence of that is losing money
so be it but now there's a new contender
in the ring threads created by meta
founder Zuckerberg the app was released
on Thursday and is growing by millions
of new users daily enough to get musk's
attention musk tweeted that competition
is fine cheating is not and his lawyers
have threatened to sue for hiring former
Twitter employees who have access to
trade secrets it's so early that it's
hard to say what uh Zuckerberg's vision
for threats is is it just to Simply take
market share from Twitter in a very
optimistic time
um you know that would be my guess
YouTuber Mr Beast seems to have picked
aside cheekly offering to give away a
Tesla with a threads logo to one of his
followers to celebrate the new platform
not that the billionaires need help
trading barbs in fact they almost ended
up in a literal cage match after it
became known Zuckerberg was learning to
fight musk went so far as to suggest a
location Vegas octagon before the whole
thing fell apart what a shame but I
guess a pair of tech Geniuses not known
for their social skills publicly
fighting for social media Supremacy is a
decent enough undercard microwlay Global
News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Anne caviola
tonight's your Canada is North Sydney
Nova Scotia we love seeing your Canada
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thank you
for watching Jeff sample will be back at
the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night